[Applause]  thank you daddy  thanks again okay okay potatoes little  chisel of olive oil so it's fresh  meatballs again ok  Patsy where your potatoes fish puzzle in  there okay and then from there put those  potatoes back into the pan okay keep  hold of your lid okay I just roll them  around now leave that to sit there and  it's gonna steam and really flavor those  potatoes nicely now pan on for the  broccoli just get on the heat let it get  hot okay someone's resting now  broccoli hold it down okay start cutting  round the idea now is to end up like a  little sort of tree like that okay don't  turn away okay  now roughly okay into a pan